[Risate]
amici si sente si vede sì sì sì ciao
allora della spiga in breve oggi
anticipo la live che sono successe cose
ho dovuto anticipa micia belli ciao a
tutti quelli che stanno entrando aspetto
un mazza che capelli aspetta un minuto
che entrano un po meno tutti un po meno
tutti l'italiano e vi spiego la
situazione nel perché ho anticipato la
live anche se penso che molti di voi
abbiano intuito
intanto il mio orologio che non è un
play senti mi sta deteriorando il polso
sto morendo ciao ciao ciao ciao franta
sti c ciao ciao belli allora un minuto e
vi dico tutto minuto vi dico tutto tanto
che aspetto che si commettono tutti
siamo fantastici ciao ciao chiamate
tutti oggi la rai va anticipata live
anticipata alle 5 da dove iniziare dieci
minuti fa ha iniziato pure nell'anticipo
iniziato in ritardo ragazzi lo
anticipata perché questa roba qua non
aspettarmi tutti usa
perché ci sono dei pikachu nostre fermi
sta roba qua è comparsa nei consigliati
in questo momento reaction abruzzo su di
lei un air al sit com ying
se
[Musica]
cosa ma perché
ma perché ma perché no non ho capito
spetta questo è successo perché sta roba
[Musica]
apache
ma perché no raga non ho capito il senso
va bene la mia comparsa sta roba nei
consigliati a del sat fermi fermi c'è un
dettato di smith poi iniziamo perché mi
riduco guarda sta roba
va bene
[Musica]
evitiamo di farci mandare alla live
amici non ho capito lovelli ben sapete
che non ho capito la lava di pikachu che
me lo spiegate comunque i binari oggi è
durato veramente niente perché adesso vi
spiego perché gli è stata dalla grafite
presto perché il video di oggi era una
trovata nel caso non si fosse capito no
ve lo faccio rivedere in live almeno
almeno uno dei capi di cosa sto parlando
anche magari con ivano l'ha visto allora
fa vj dove cercarmi per trovare i miei
video perché non li trova latina
perfetto questo qua e il video di oggi
rispetto che ve lo faccio vedere così
almeno capiamo cosa stiamo facendo ha
forse la mia webcam copre quella
originale spe fermi 31 2008 l'ispettore
and james è a caccia del 6 archivi ha
chiamato lady day
l'ultima vittima dei suoi crimini e
stata trovata in un hotel economico sta
investigando attualmente c'è il video di
oggi dura un minuto 36 ragazzi perché a
un certo punto succede questo la faccio
breve ha detto mazza che buio permesso
sto cercando una killer
[Musica]
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
come se viene preceduto c'è un documento
è un bel mi piace al video sono stata
quesiti iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci
vediamo allora allora faccio questa live
in anticipo perché da questo video sono
sorti milioni di dubbi man detto a ciao
ragazzi che poi vi risponde ad una serie
sono sotto i milioni di dubbi perché
that bomba e cosa è successo perché era
da una vita che volevo fare un video era
da una vita che volevo fare un video del
genere per quale motivo perché
immaginatevi quelli che già oggi nessuno
lo capisce ma immaginatevi quelli che ti
potrai 56 anni si trovano sto mio video
che si chiama il numero 1 oro nel 2019 e
si trovano sta roba
dovevo far archiviare un vivo nel mio
canale del genere da sempre volevo fare
finalmente l'ho fatto grazie già class
quindi oggi volevo iniziare line prima
uno perché vide odoravano minuto e mezzo
quindi non c'è il video di giornata
allora iniziava la prima la finirò per
le 8 tempo di ovada dia ora quando
adatta a cena la finisco la inizio prima
almeno copre un po il pomeriggio visto
che erano fatte uscire niente di
duraturo capito mi fa ridere il fatto
che quei video stilato da dio a volte
farcito di sei ora che fanno di kakà a
volte facendo un minuto che vanno così
bene va tra l'altro mi fa ridere
voi non avete notato niente tipo questa
cosa poi non l'avete notato
io ve la faccio vedere nel momento in
cui arriva arriva il tipo che si
schianti io sapevo cosa stavo giocando
perché avevo già giocato domani esce un
video dove ci gioca per la prima volta
anche se c'è una reazione quella vera
questo lo sapevo già alla sta per
succedere e grazie fabio e pur sapendo
cosa stava per succedere io che mi
trattengo un sacco da ridevo datemi la
fa guardate la mia faccia qua guardatela
io vi sta trattenendo tantissimo dare il
nostro se si vede
l'ho registrato tre volte è stato
difficilissimo per me a registrare
questo video vi viene altro guarda che
guarda che faccia guardalo
mi veniva troppo da ridere quindi niente
mi trovai dove farla la prima perché
sennò giustamente non jared di un minuto
e mezzo durante la giornata
dovevo farlo dovevo io dovevo fare
questa scusate mi dovevo fare questa che
non potevo non fare questa cosa pardon
ma dovevo fare assolutamente sta roba mi
veniva troppo da ridere ma avevo bisogno
di un video sul mio canale che rimanesse
nei secoli e che non avesse un senso
questo è il video in questione
grazie a tutti grazie già collage video
di oggi si nota diverso per le qualità
di sub grazie mille ogni giorno miglioro
grazie fabio appunto pikachu parade
grazie starlight cosa vuol dire cos'è la
pikachu parade che fa una parata di
pikachu cos'era quella roba che abbiamo
visto prima di pikachu ragazzi qualcuno
me lo spiega io non l'ho capita non lo
sono visto negoziati del dub e clicco
però non ha senso
tra l'altro iniziava primi 30 20 visto
video sono riesce una cosa oggi ha
scoperto il mio canale preferito
volevo far vedere il mio canale
iscrivetevi a tutti a sta roba
il mio canale preferito di tutto youtube
e questo sì tutto tutto youtube è questo
qua per chi di voi ha giocato oblivion
sa di cosa stiamo parlando chi non l'ha
giocato no però questo è il mio canale
preferito youtube
nac romanzi mobili col pensiero di band
basta cesti video sì questa non mi ha
detto che l'ho visto un miliardo di
volte però sti video sono i più belli
che io abbia mai visto su youtube cioè
sta roba qua e g questo fa miliardi di
views giusta roba di oblivion quanto
fatto male tipo anche a questo e questo
e per questo geniale questo e ancora
meno 18 secondi gli ha dato i soldi
moglie gli ruba prendili tanto non mi
servono lo stesso vale appena derubati
cosa c'è ragazzi io non ho veramente per
questi sarei questo mio canale nuovo
preferito di youtube non ha senso ma lo
preferisco a qualsiasi cosa vi lamentate
del video corto perfette chi fa video vi
ricordo va bene allora cerca pikachu
parade e capire non so cosa sia la
pikachu parenti giuro non so cosa sia
pikachu pikachu parade
non ho idea ripensi a pikachu parade
quanto sto facendo miliardi transizioni
prof
io
per cui non mi spiega starà
cos'è la pikachu parade ce l'ha già la
gente va vestita in giro vestita da
pikachu in giappone ma perché è perché
lo fanno
[Applauso]
non ho capito il senso di star c'è ed è
bello però non capisco perchè lo fanno
lo fanno a caso all'uscita di un pokemon
nuovo tu sei
[Musica]
la madonna difesa c'è di strano
come già come il giappone celebra
l'elettricità japanese preparing for war
[Applauso]
qualcuno mi spiega sta roba perché la
fanno scusami ma poi tutto questo è
partito da un video di che non c'entra
niente il bellissimo non so come altro
di scrivere questa roba non sono no no
no vi sono stati in giappone non ho
visto cotanta bellezza ma me ne pento
non ho idea di cosa sia la pica supera
io perché la facciano però
[Applauso]
complimenti per la fantasia c'è qua non
possiamo fare la salvini parade c se ci
vestiamo di salvi youtube cimo white
sarebbe del molo guardi spett.le venire
a bologna ciao rugby grazie mi è anche
il video ct come la politica americana e
un meme a può essere a bologna ci verrò
molto presto promessa ciao paolo grazie
mille ciao giuliano data dalla data
della cia vanno ciava motian ludo ciao
gigi ciao florim cupcake alle super elia
vincenzo e jean tutti fratelli
però idea di cosa sia la pikachu parade
però fino cioè lo fanno a caso cioè fa
non ha pagate basta questo jimmy
weinstein per curiosità
come vede semplicemente la roba musica
lizzata sc muoio ricordo è un grande
anyway certo che salverà live la caprese
thank you
ci ha donato allora cominciamo oggi
volevo farvi volevo volevano vedere una
roba al bonus
il primo gioco di oggi è carino un gioco
che non avete ancora visto però devo
devo appurare una roba che ho detto a me
lo faccio il live almeno assenso il
fatto che abbia fatto cadere il
pomeriggio
voglio provare questo c'è poi da la cosa
[ __ ] che that trips il gioco che ho
fatto
dura c'è pesa 250 mega non ha senso ma
niente un gioco che non ha niente come
fa pesare così tanto ciao sergio welcome
back the che so much for the nation
brada glie l'ho visto ciccio a proposito
che ballava ma c'è
sembra un caso incredibile non ho messo
del trips per un attimo che lo trovo ok
ciao francesca di allora i video ci
riprova volevo provare a fare questa
cosa solo per curiosità perchè non ho
quando giocate ha detto ips la prima
volta non ho provato a fare una roba che
hanno provato a a fare altre persone
lui però ci anch'io almeno riprendono
adoro rimasto queste tetrixx gioco fatto
oggi
ciao ragazza noemi ciao giulia un bacio
ciao mia un certo che tornerò in puglia
for eventi e roba del genere promesso
allora la cosa che non ho provato a fare
perché poi c'è una chiave che non avevo
visto che tutti hanno preso tranne
perché però fatto provato a tutti i miei
amici voglio provare andare al piano di
sopra e vedere cosa succede se levo il
vaso dove casca al tizio ci devo provare
almeno una volta almeno ci provi il live
leva lo leggano
[Musica]
è inceppato lo stesso ok quindi non puoi
neanche toglierlo ma se io la supero lo
rifaccio lo rifaccio fammelo di fare
porca vacca fame o rifare gli ep the
wall sreet carina devo provare c'è una
buccia è un modo per finirlo e lo so me
lo sento c'è modo per andare avanti a
che non può essere solo presto stati non
ho provato a fare nient'altro che questo
dai dovevo fare un video così almeno
oggi play era fighissimo dai di temi
suonerà il video più bello del 2019 che
abbiamo fatto pochi video però se io ci
vado invece proprio incontro come se
volessi terramare prova fare tutti i
test
ciao già class anch'io aspetta
tu non puoi aia che testata mi è passato
attraverso le attirato l'attrice niente
ci devi finire proprio male vabbè
grazie alberto navarro davvero nel video
di domani anche comunque ci gioco ma a
linz faccio due horror domani uno
all'inizio e uno alla fine che sarebbe
questo quello alla fine della prima
volta che veramente ho giocato a sto
gioco quindi vedete la mia prima
reaction io penso che questo sia il
gioco che più bello horror indica abbia
mai fatto e sono serio non è un ironico
perché geniale e penso sia veramente
geniale sto gioco vera e non penso
esista gioco più geniale di questo
veramente chi l'ha fatto
alberto novaro è un genio punto punto
non sono ironico perché non nessuno
aveva pensato a fare questa cosa c'è
nessuno è una cavolata farlo ma nessuno
ci aveva pensato quindi se non è e
geniale milano fa un freddo boia sergio
però grazie per avermelo chiesto e io ho
un pelino di influenza solo perché mi
hanno attaccate ciccio perché ce l'ha
avuta due settimane fa quindi non posso
avere la febbre quella cazzuta per un
pelo cielo siete bene si sente bene cosa
volete che giochiamo oggi volete voi
allora abbiamo teoria
tf simulator giocato serio perché
stavolta ho sbloccato un sacco di roba
quindi posso andare a rubare scuse [ __ ]
rocket oppure la lista solita quindi
ditemi voi cosa volete che giochi rocket
bordi di voi
volendo io sto aprendo la lista nel
mentre sei vien in mente qualcosa
ditemelo
allora parte che ciò l'htc bailo adesso
possono recare le cose rock e the rocket
rocket rocket venditrici eviterei
roxanne sicuri facciamo rocca e dava
facciamo così visto che è una roba tra
rock e hip simulator di temi prima
rocket primati simulator faccio prima
uno poi l'altro faccio fino alle sei e
mezza 1 poi il resto faccio l'altro così
facciamo un po di tutti e due contenti a
un po tutti ok a rocket all altro
ditemi voi prima faccio uno poi l'altro
capisco solo la quale fare prima come
fare dopo
prima rocket che balle che non si
possono fare i sondaggi perché mi è
difficile capire quanti rocket e quanti
tipi sono scritti tiff rocket non si
capisce quale prima quale dopo verso non
è che possa passare dai bar camp cerca
di capire quale prima quale dopo
facciamo prima volta troppe tip
simulator lo faccio per le sei e mezza
ok fatto uguale ed è un 50 50 quindi
fare prima con o l'altro è completamente
indifferente prima racket poi l'altro ok
per che preferisci rocket a fort knight
beh perché lo reputo un gioco più perché
ora il punto più un gioco
se non gioco più in più un gioco solo
per quel motivo di perché poi è
tecnicamente bello c'è va anche a culo
ma dipende veramente quanto sei bravo e
io non lo sono
va bene tanto non cambia niente ragazzi
perché prima facevano poi l'altro ad
avere persone sei e mezza fai pensare
sì sei e mezzo 640 inizio l'altro va
bene così tanto facciamo un paio gli
under e simulator potrei anche
aggiungersi dai dopo faccio un pelo gli
under tira più un pelo di rockets che un
pelo di under
lo trovate il joystick un attimo lega
cioè non tra il cavo del giorgi eccolo
white
ciao gamer ciad o amici
non faceva caldo a milano sicuro c'è
dipende come sei abituato io ho freddo
anche a 10 gradi
io ho sempre freddo anche d'estate
quindi è un po un problema mio quello va
bene proviamo un paio di singolo allora
ragazzi da un po che non gioco
dall'ultima live quindi mi devo tutelare
dal fatto che potrò fare schifo let's go
non schifo fare gli under e seriamente
sai potrei fare gli under e anche dopo
in realtà però il pre anche gli under
simulator dopo un po diventa noioso
perché non sai cosa fare però posso
provarci alla giochiamo un po a rocket
poi alle sei e mezza faccia almeno
almeno mezz'ora e tagliandole se ci
divertiamo continuiamo anche alle 16 st
6 e mezza 6 40 facciamo un periodi young
vediamo allora io qua sono roncato
platino 3 quindi la vedo veramente
grigia di riuscire a fare una bella
partita pro possiamo iniziare
positivamente magari ecco con un detto
porca vacca quando ai partiti la devo
perdere subito si vede immediatamente ci
provano a fare figure di kakà raga però
siamo ad ora anche veramente alto qua
siamo a platino 3 quindi ci potrebbe
stare la figuretta di kakà non è vero
niente questo ma saltato in tutti i modi
possibili ci proviamo regali non so se
siamo anche un po alto qua quindi non so
l'ultima volta vi devo solo classificare
quindi era un po più easy bel po crisi
però attenzione
no tra l'altro ho notato che io sto
gioco 4 anche sulla play e sulla play
sono quattro ora anche indietro io ero
convinto di essere all'angolo della
mappa molto bene convinto proprio ma per
mai pensavo di essere al centro della
porta
vabbè temporeggiato un pelo troppo
volevi ad ora fa mi concentravo
ora uno simola
quello con gli script altro la ola
stavolta all immagine di stormi l'ultima
volta di youtube che io facciamo che
ogni live metto la foto di uno youtuber
diverso così caso nel nell'avatar volevi
passare fratello occhio cristiano ancora
lui barco lo schifo quello la che riesce
a teletrasportarsi e mori
dono su oggi spacco le orecchie ragazzi
difficile giocare al platino 3 ve lo
assicuro non sono dio non credo neanche
di meritare nel platino 3 quello il
fatto però vabbè lo so noi giochiamo ci
vieni fratello carica amico un puledro
ragazzi avete farmi domande o robe del
genere ma che con le donazioni fatelo
solo nell'inter mezzo nel caso perché se
no non riesco a leggere quando in gioco
perché se mi distraggo nati o più gol
quindi nelle pause leggo tutto
volevi togli non ci credo mai madonna
cosa gli ho preso riparti frate vado a
controllare ma guarda che pezzente ok
raga questo ce la portiamo a casa forse
dico forse perché il rocket non sei mai
sicuro fino all'ultimo secondo
però normale normale non male
let's go a ragala volete la serie
diversità in tv serio e adesso sto
parlando non anon il live intendo quando
esce quando esce però non in live che la
dovrei montare per bene
ditemi voi ditemi se volete residenti vo
dai
[Musica]
ma basta madonna demolisco ma dalla
prossima volta li faccio saltare il
computer
questi uomini di morire di tutta la
partita e mi demolisce dove vai
ciao giacomo farà speciale c 48 iscritti
io a tutti spero che un giorno si
arriverà anche tu va bene va bene
ciao fratello mi sa che questa è la
chiudiamo asia si è arreso prima ragazzi
incredibile ho vinto la prima è
difficile vincere le app latino 3a non
sono platino due manderà kato perché so
platino due non ricordo perchè sono
platino due ha forse perché ho giocato
un ciccio l'altro giorno boh che strano
e roma 0 3
ma ecco perché mi sembra avrà niente a
posto giusto così
c'è allora ci sarà qualcuno giocare con
te adesso dc ma vorrei fare questa cosa
quando attivo gli abbonamenti a
proposito ragazzi gli abbonamenti oli
attivo come ormai non fatto banco solo
io praticamente non hanno fatto tutti
tranne io alla fine del mese e inizio
febbraio quindi farò una roba
probabilmente per poi giocare tutti
insieme visto che se no come far ciò
siete tanti però in qualche modo
facciamo da quando attivo questa roba
vediamo se riusciamo a farlo ok
l'asd prossimo la partita normale
figurativa diamond ue come devo giocare
ai giochi nell'inferno giochi veramente
nell'inferno sei un campione 9 veramente
non sai come come giocano con i forti
let's go
c'è un aspetto che c'è un'altra scelta
di gioco oltre ai andrea era gas e tia
partiti simulator intendi se vi viene in
mente qualcos'altro si se vi inventate
voi un gioco che non esiste spetta non
c'è tanta roba [ __ ]
ma che anche tipo yandle e perché non lo
porto molto spesso perché gli underdog
può diventare i peti cf le stesse cose
sono lo porterei moto di spesso però
purtroppo sono stato molto bravo vai ma
morto tua sorella aspetta buono non mi
marino di caricare non mi caricare
figlio del nulla dai che schifo che ho
fatto qua mi sono impegnato per fare
schifo
minchia che tiro
beghe
sono contento di portare un gioco dove
almeno almeno almeno me la cavo nonché
faccio schifo non sono il più forte ma
neanche il più scarso tipo per quello
eviterei di portare tipo forti night il
tipo mi fa e rocket league non forza
horizon me la scritta in chat che voi
non leggete a si sono pagati così ai
lati delle chat
quando succede una live speciale ragazzi
le live quelle speciali sono
riconosciute dal fatto che si bagarre
cosa dell'elettricità di fianco per
quale ho sbagliato perfetto però l'ho
saltato perché non so come mai ogni
tanto si paga quello a fare sai forse
perché l'ho spostato può essere forse
quando lo sposto mi si pagano le cose
elettrica non lo so
aveva dopo la giusto senza voglia
bello bello li gigi gigi si of thieves è
massimo scoperto ci sono da solo cities
non è carino da far da solo
dovrei farlo con qualcuno capito perché
si acquista solo è brutto sembra proprio
nei cieli vai vai a pilotare non è
proprio il massimo
credo quindi eviterei e figo ma non solo
the witcher 3 non ci ho mai giocato
quindi direi no rainbow six
io non mi ci vedo mai giocare rainbow
six player a non ne call of duty in me
a proposito sta per tornare una serie
che ho registrato oggi con il buon
pietro se indovinate che serie vincete
un saluto visto che al mondo non contano
gli amori le amicizie conta se farsi
salutare la famiglia in i video perché
leggo solo quello dal mattino alla sera
verremo in sardegna ha voglia
very good ciao giulia molecole ratio che
hanno visto visualizzati l'ho già visto
la gama erano d'accordo gli ho risposto
quindi non c'è bisogno che faccia di
action lo so già come
mamma mia
schifoso che meriti la la gogna e la
fogna amore
e dove vai
minecraft harcourt ragazzi è uscito un
minecraft parkour che devastante oggi
abbiamo registrato i primi due episodi
vi assicuro è bellissimo qua non so come
ho fatto a demolirlo è successo e basta
ma che m'ha fregato lui qua qua mi ha
proprio fregato lui mai il nuovo my car
parkour che uscirà non adesso tra un
paio di settimane fa quando esce in
realtà ma dai
che sfiga incredibile il nome anche a
falcone è bellissimo però prima vorrei
fare residenti vol
vorrei fare tutto residenti voleè una
volta fatto residenti vol minecraft
parkour quello nuovo sarà spettacolare
abbiamo iniziato a registrarlo adesso
con tutto questo anticipo ancora non ha
anche fatto residenti vol perché è
lunghissimo ragazzi il nuovo banca
procure veramente lungo e difficile del
più bello di tutti viber ve lo assicuro
perchè ci sta mettendo un sacco è
veramente figo però uscirà dopo
residenti voi perché ci stiamo mettendo
proprio tanto a farlo vorrei prima
finirlo tutto e poi pubblicare i video
che pezzo di culo se vabbè vabbè
e veramente figo mike far correre
ve lo giuro questo qua incredibile voi
non avete idea porco demonio schifoso
morto porca vacca aspetta
raga qua non so se sto facendo schifo io
sto avendo sfiga perché incredibile ha
fatto tre gol che non non li capisco
guarda guarda questa persa però non
meritata la sconfitta completamente una
più sfiga dell'altra o quando la merito
lo dico equa in questo caso secondo me
no però vabbè è andata così
ci ho messo una vita a capire che si
quali sfondo dicono honigmann one more
vorrei mai a verona no presidenti vole
bellissimo devo fare tutto residenti vo
i due perché è bellissimo ho fatto la
demo è bob baer lo farò assolutamente
presidenti con la finisco residenti vole
faccio manca sparkle che oriente mi
aspetto io ho svelato la serie prima le
due serie che usciranno da qui a fine
marzo tipo perché mai caparco dura
veramente un sacco non so quanto
residenti vol ma secondo me la sentivo
il 45 pisa disco nome maic rafa ancora
anche dieci perché durata ricevere non
avete idea di quanta roba c'è
il tipo di mister che si chiama mister
mystics che serve be nice
non so dirlo in inglese che sarebbe
mister mi guardi con liriche mortis
bellissima star o la cosa sto facendo
schifo
nelle ultime due partite sto facendo
pietà però va bene non si sapesse sono
io scherzo cosa ma guarda
ma figlio di un coso
la mia frega e si va bene era che non se
ne sta meritando ma per niente ma che
sfiga ma basta ma guardava qua fatta a
finirli madame amiche ma non è possibile
dai cheppallle perché io odio perdere
quando non mi merito di perdere che
fastidio che mila ti devi togliere o
sbagliato io no ragazzi incredibile in
tre questa partita incredibile peggiori
quali prima non si è meritato mezzo gol
4 una fatti in due minuti
neanche un minuto e mezzo guarda guarda
che culo tutte da me ma cribbio
no questa sbagliato io ho sbagliato io
ci manca solo che entrava anche questa
mano andava a che tanto me ne vado
uguale mi faccio un tipo 3 gol in un
secondo l'ho persa
no no non so cosa mi stia prendendo
basta
le ultime due partite sono da prendere e
buttare nel cesso perché bestiami nei
video mai bestemmiato in un video poi
ero lory è questo andato male non vanno
tutte bene sei una sega tuo padre bacino
giovanna a caso residenti vol 49 chino e
poi l'ho giocato tipo mese in mese fa no
però qualche mese fa mario dissi no
perché anche quello non è recente
i residenti il film di residenti lo che
mi è piaciuto di più quello dove sono mi
ricordo che residenti vole coloro che
sono in quel palazzo che ci atterrano
con la regola aereo non mi ricordo quale
dei mille no no ma per carità ma no no
no no ma per carità non deve essere gol
quello segnato insegnato prego prego
credibile
controlla poi questo è riuscita a
prendere il turbo controlla la palla
cioè no vabbè ma questa che sta
succedendo nelle tre punti nei tre
partite questo fece caso c'è cos'è cos'è
sta roba
ma cosa sto giocando ho cambiato
minecraft giocando a minecraft non è
vero che lui
che schifo di partite guarda gli altri
mi avrebbero fatto un gol
gli avrebbe dato otto punti c'è una
ragazza ne perde un'altra così riesco
proprio cambio gioco perché non ha senso
non entra niente o ho mica se non
entrava quest'area davoli brown star non
mi fa vomitare
brawl starfort knight clash royale tutti
quei giochi con i clic facili che fanno
un sacco di altre persone da me non li
avrete perché io faccio giochi che mi
piacciono
c'è me ne sbatto le palle si faccia meno
virus se faccio meno spettatori
io gioco quello che mi piace se volete
roba che fai uso andate da altra gente
non da affrontare io l'ho non so neanche
come si neanche so niente potrebbe
essere un gioco di calcio per quanto mi
riguarda non lo so sono a che cosa si sa
solo che è un gioco di quelli da click
facile allora ho detto a me non lo porta
precedenti per magari e figo è però
subito
faccio formarsi
tra i punti può andare sempre bene tutto
solo tre partite che non entra niente
cioè almeno quello another world al me
l'hai sparata a caso o hai sparato un
gioco che ti piace perché se hai sparato
gioco che ti piace quello è uno dei
giochi più storici del mondo io ho
finito tipo 3 4 volte e vecchio però all
al gatto non so se s'è visto anche la
lag deve deve agevolare sta gente che
già fa segna per caso io devo le gare io
vabbè mai che leggano loro no
preciso
no perché turbo short list per leggerla
chat
ti giuro su dio che se prendo un altro
gol così inizia con me ne vado
me ne vado che schifo che che partita
brutta ma toma che brutto
che schifo di gol sta facendo questo non
ho preso il tour
giuro su dio me ne vada prossima partita
che perdo così me ne vado non non merita
neanche di essere finita o fa il turbo e
qua ho fatto così come queste turbo
così ho fatto porco demonio morto porco
porco porco demonio morto non è
possibile
tre partite che faccio pagare cosa mi
sto già vinto le prime due sembrava gesù
cos'è successo
boh cosa è successo
ma poi fanno cagare sti avversari
giocano di perdere quando me lo merito
dico minchia filo trovato una versione
fortissima sono contento di aver perso
perché se lo merita ma mica questi fanno
schifo fanno veramente schifo l'ho fatta
perdere tre partite con questi che pena
garantirò ciofeca guarda sera ecco se io
e se io ero l'avversario la palla era
dentro cosa vi capire che cosa succede
in pista partito
molto bene
indovina chi sa chi ha vinto il
contrasto o no vabbè
ma cosa cazzo sta succedendo cosa cosa
succede ma [ __ ] vado cosa cosa
succede sto partito e guarda ke skifo
dai ma come come questo quale errore che
non avrei mai fatto non raga non so cosa
mi stia prendendo giuro proprio guarda
guarda non entra niente insegna lui
adesso segna noi adesso segna lui
ragazzi incredibile incredibile
non so cosa stia succedendo penoso cos'è
cos'è nora che incredibile c'e veramente
non so cosa stia v
giuro se per il cambio se faccio questa
a prescindere come la faccia ancora una
se perdo quella dopo cambia gioco oggi
non è il giorno dei fori nei cieli
riforma indie rocker che schifo e la
residenti afterlife
r
niente
il blog traversa palo incrocio gol
si ok tutto il traversa palo go va bene
non ho preso il turbo per quale motivo
soldi soldi soldi soldi soldi tutto
cambiato gioco
sentiamo un altra roba qualsiasi roba
perché oggi però che proprio lo devo
tocca gente non sa manco tenere il
joystick in mano e mibac bo davvero
incredibile incredibile la fortuna ti ha
abbandonato no non è questo ogni fortuna
è questione di non avere sfortuna c'è
nomi non importa non avere la fortuna
basta non avere la sfortuna basta essere
nel mezzo che quando fai le cose giuste
entra quando fare cose sbagliate
esci cambiamo shogun meglio perché sta
andando in una maniera che non capisco
non faccio neanche quella dopo per
provare perché non ha veramente senza
cambio avevo il gioco a prescindere
facciamo tipo
[Musica]
facciamo gli under e poi facciamo
l'altro quello di tip simulator perché
gli under e potrebbe mi piace la gente
che scrive gli under simulator come se
gli andriesi una lettera ogni volta
avesse nuove cose da offrire non ce le
ha ogni volta è sempre uguale a meno che
non faccia degli aggiornamenti quindi
immagino ci siano degli aggiornamenti
vediamo come va ciao azzurra
ciao arianna ha visto il film the queen
e beam e quindi a prescindere
li amo da morire fiandre va bene gli
under per quanto non abbia niente di
nuovo
credo credo devo scaricarlo solo regala
un attimo però perché non ce lo più da
una vita però lo scarico vediamo ha
fatto un sacco di aggiornamenti perché
non leggi le donazioni l'ho appena lette
6 sordo super meat boy forever quando
esce magari battlefield 5 non sono
proprio cento se come non ha tanto senza
fare battlefield sul mio canale a sto
scaricando vabbè ci mette cinque minuti
poi col tempo di farne ancora uno solo
che vediamo sempre il caso finisce bene
almeno una sola poi andare perché tanto
deve scaricare ci mette 5 punti ce li
mette quindi proviamo a rocket ultima
volta solo per la de amicis l'oscar
perché mica incredibile
dai semi other ancato a platino 1
platino 1 i bambini delle elementari
giocano qua platino uno sull'altro so
platino 3 come possibile sito riprendere
che aspetta dai height rai
guardava il credito
gli under e non c'è nulla di nuovo
controllato è vaglielo a spiegare agli
altri
mi piace la gente che dice così c'è chi
vi faccio un altro esempio tipo no è
tipo happy with no non ritornare
sull'argomento è più di cinque minuti
per evitare di farlo ma vabbè ecco qua
ha meritato lui ma se segna se lo merita
se lo merita
quando ci vuole ci vuole del meritato
perché ha fatto il movimento giusto qua
se l'è meritato tutti gli altri dieci
gol compreso negli ultime ore no neanche
uno qua c'è il senso questo che ha fatto
quindi per carità questo non ha senso
l'esempio tipo gli scorso e tipo happy
with no la gente mi chiede ma come fai a
richiedermi è più rischi di un gioco che
uguale negli ultimi sei anni è rimasto
prima traversa palo gol quello di prima
era entrata è da meno ceduta ributta
dentro io rischia di non entrare
questo sempre per farvi capire torniamo
al discorso di happy meals happy wheels
è un gioco che mi chiede gli chiede la
gente ma me lo richiede per moda c'è nel
senso fi è più insomma loro non sanno
neanche che cosa sta dicendo ce lo fanno
perché non lo so neanche come se fosse
un tic nervoso
ciao comandata dai fai è prevista la
giornata andata bene fai è più idrata
bene è un tic c'è nel senso non ha senso
perché è più uguale a come era otto anni
fa e non è cambiato niente ci sono
sempre gli stessi livelli sempre le
stesse cose non cambia di una virgola
tutto uguale tutto uguale sempre un po
straziante perché comunque file imporsi
con una 220 episodi poi dice vabbè dai
basta e quindi per quello che non faccio
è uguale non cambia niente sarebbero
tutti i video uguali uno ogni domenica
uscirebbe un video quale la domenica
prima che senso ha
non vedo il senso un conto è quando
rifai tipo di episodi tipo adesso
riportato tipo gretel e hansel che avevo
già fatto tempo fano perchè era da un
botto che non lo portava non mi
ricordavo come era guarda che culo a
questo e quindi ha senso ma happy lewis
che è tutto uguale
non ha senso cioè identico non trovo
sfizio io nel giocarci non mi diverto
perché è sempre uguale e non so come si
diverta la gente secondo me quelli che
dicono porta è pv si guarda che culo
quelli che dicono porta è più questo
secondo me non sanno non si rendono
conto man coloro che non lo
guarderebbero neanche cenicola protetti
di spaccio e non lo guardano perché è
uguale a com'era milan
non me lo chiedere qua avuto culo anche
io quindi mi sono ripreso dalla sfiga di
prima attenzione non ho turbo gol suo il
suo sì ci sta ci sta perché il nuovo
turbo e divertente vederti revocare
madonne con happy è ma non è uguale tipo
è uguale a come era sempre cioè vabbè mi
incavolo con l'impossible figo poi fossi
uno youtuber normale che un papa è stato
pazzo non ha saltato per quale motivo
bataille porca vacca
c'è tipo di youtube ma porco demonio
come fai essere ovunque quanti tour
bilic aghi va a cagare tipo youtuber di
oggi fanno tutti fort night tobruk stars
quello che mi avete nominato prima che
non ho mai neanche toccato perché fabio
belli capisco cioè il senso ha oggi una
giornata di merda
questi non sanno tenere un joystick in
mano e segnano portano brawl stars è
forte perché comunque vabbè youtube è
loro business io li capisco cioè non è
che è di cibo lo porta a porta in fa
schifo cioè il suo lavoro e farlo
youtuber magari gli fa anche cagare però
ci sta che lo fa io fortunatamente e
questo lo dico grazie a voi perché mi
avete portato ad un punto in altissimo
livello di iscritti posso grazie a dio
permettermi di non fare le cose che mi
fanno cagare tipo forse non è vero
fornendomi fa cagare
però posso permettermi di non fare cose
che non mi va di fare ad esempio forte
tilo giocare contro voglia
altri youtube e magari che lo stanno
giocando il suo periodo lo giocano
controvoglia ma non lo dico non è anche
perché gli fabius cioè se io portassi
for tanti in questa live invece di 6000
spettatori anche se me ne conta la metà
di quelli che sono per essere stati sui
12mila prova viva i bug avrei di più
però non me ne frega niente cioè non sto
facendo live per quel motivo li faccio
mai perché a me piace giocare fare un
paio di lega settimana mi mi piace
perché non devo montare il video gioco a
rob e nel mentre parlo chiacchiero con
voi quindi mimì a me piace questa roba
qua e lo preferisco molto di più a fort
knight
ste robe qui anche se faccio meno
spettatori tua madre è veramente brutta
e quindi non mi vedrete mai giocare a
forti per lamentarmi le views una roba
che non grazie a dio posso permettermi
di non farlo perché ormai arrivati a 5
milioni di iscritti grazie a dio posso
però fare quello che che mi va di fare e
gr ed è grazie a voi se ne avessi di
meno sarei costretto a far fornte come
gli altri che sarà per blue stars a me
non piace non si giochi questo era oro
303 oro 3 oro 3 oro 3 un oro tre fa
schifo oro 3 oro shock questo non sa
manco come si scrive rocket league mi ha
battuto oro 3 fa ridere ci guardate la
villa live dell'altra volta
boh comunque oggi rocket e prendere a
buttare quando io ho notato che quando
su rocket non so giocare ho notato quel
non so non so come mai non so come mai
ma io ho notato questa cosa quando su
rocket vinco una partita ne vinco due
sono nel modo giusto ne vinco un sacco
tipo la scorsa live quando su rocket
perdo né perdona ne perdo 2 puoi dare il
joystick in mano a un bambino di due
anni e io quella la perdo il mio
avversario a due anni magari li faccio
10 a 0 e poi crasha la connessione in
qualche modo la devo perdere quando sono
in serie di sconfitte puoi dare in mano
il joystick a un cerebroleso e quello mi
batte quando invece sono in serie di
vittorie poi dare in mano il joystick a
un professionista e gli faccio un mazzo
così io non ho la via di mezzo questo
faceva pena e ho perso magari domani
sono in mood giusto e vinco contro i
diamanti che sono tipo di otto rank
avanti non so come mai porta vermi ted
con tom non c'è tom cioè non l'ho
sentito era tanto però facciamo gli
under vediamo come avente come
cambiato
vediamo come aspetta che esco
siamo al 93 per 194 datemi ancora un
paio di minuti e joe chiamai under e
vediamo com'è perché non ho idea se è
migliorato speriamo di sì spero vi
piaccia residenti vaud che voglio fare
perché veramente ci tengo un sacco a me
piace tanto porterai under the hill non
penso perché c'è lorenzo ciò lorenzo
ciao matti ciao francesco non voglio
fare cities loro perchè non non so altro
c'è è bello inglesi ortiz e berlin
gruppo da solo né bruttino quindi no
allora diciamo porterei mai under the il
no perché under the hill a una community
molto molto molto simile è sbalzata la
voce è sentito molto simile a quelli a
quella di di fort nate cioè nel senso se
tu non giochi come dice la gente ti
pagano le palle e io odio quando la
gente mi dice che cosa fare vi faccio un
esempio
tante persone mi chiedevano di giocare
ad adverteam e io ho portato del tar 1 e
no perché perché andiate l'avevo già
visto tutti allora ho fatto un
ragionamento ho detto porto del tar one
del taro detto non ho ancora vi dove si
dice che non è una storia collegata ad
under the sono due storie diverse che
hanno dei riferimenti ad under the hills
e nel senso se tu non hai giocato ad
under the hill non fuori non puoi fare
non puoi capire delle cose che ci sono
in del tar un è ok e mi andava benissimo
cioè io quando iniziato del terreno
detto ok ci gioco e non capirò delle
cose che sto facendo
la trama è sua idea se però non capire
delle cose che sto facendo perché per
capirle devo giocare ad under tail ma è
bello che sia così perché le persone che
hanno giocato ad under tail mi sapranno
dire a cavolo tutto il riferimento non
l'hai capito è invece questa cosa era
così perché oppure era così scoprirai
quando giocherai ad under tail questa
era il mio intento
invece no la situazione è stata ho
giocato a delta rune e i commenti era un
tipo e perché questo perché hai deciso
giocare prima del tar un e invece che
under tele era quella cosa che volevo
generare io però a livello incazzo
perché c'è nel senso io l'ho fatto
apposta perché volevo giocare un
qualcosa innanzi tutto di nuovo perché
del tallone non avevano fatto ancora in
pochi e poi giocare ad under the il dopo
del terrore perché mi è piaciuta l'ho
detto è giochiamo ad under the hill che
almeno capisco le cose che non avevo
capito nel talune il risultato è stato
che ha fatto poche views però vabbè
chissenefrega per il discorso sempre di
prima ma quelle poche bis che sono state
fatte erano tutte fatte da persone
tossiche di under the che scrivano nervi
si gioca così si fa così si fa cosa mi
hanno fatto passare la voglia
quindi non farò undertake se me lo farò
lo farò per i cavoli miei senza nessuno
che mi paga le pal perché io odio quando
una persona mi dice come devo fare le
cose cioè io le voglio fare in un certo
modo le faccio quindi under the hill e
molto probabilmente un capolavoro
peccato per la community
peccato per la community di andate lei
non lo dico io è lo dicono un sacco di
persone e giocando del tar una ho capito
perché perché se la community è proprio
un po inquinata cioè se tu non fai le
cose come devono essere fatte secondo
loro è fa schifo è un gioco che permette
di avere più scelte quindi è figo che io
abbia le mie scelte perché devo avere le
tue è brutto quindi mi hanno fatto
passare la voglia non farò mai under
tail sul canale lo farò per i cavoli
miei
peccato per questo è comunque in tutto
questo ha finito da un ora di fare gli
under e quindi possiamo giocare da
vediamo come è finito come si è ridotto
under vescovo cece bellissimo che questo
è per niente il gioco in continuo
sviluppo per questo da quattro anni
[Musica]
cosa ne pensi la mitica anche sta roba
non vi ho detto
censurato la parolaccia avete visto the
world records
ecco figo c'è ci sta come cosa perché ha
veramente demolito tutti regole però una
cosa che non ho capito come ha fatto il
tipo a fare tutti stielike perchè si è
portato sicuro in qualche modo ma non
per cattiveria perché tante volte è
successo che tante persone volessero
fare questa cosa del world record e lui
ci è riuscito
e come se si fosse comprato
1 o 2 milioni di like in qualche modo e
da quei like poi si è sponsorizzato non
lo so
e l'ha fatto arrivare a tutti in qualche
modo si è aiutato però non è che ha
aperto una pagina del dove facciamo il
record è affatto recco si è sicuramente
sponsorizzato è impossibile perché sennò
è strano
è in sviluppo da un secolo perché chi lo
crea una persona sola si si lo so lo so
infatti per carità tanta roba
però mi fa ridere che sia ancora in bill
il tipo the forest per uscire ci ha
messo sei anni
cosa fare quattro game
raga da una vita che non lo gioco what
gender jesi e dalle note
ciao chi ribatte un bacino di mail ma
come la prima cosa che ho fatto
cosa vuoi scegliere maschio femmina
femmina
no non puoi da allora poi non mi serve
una feature così difficile ma dai
questa lo metti a fare lo promettere mi
ha sempre deve essere uomo vabbè
famiglie fari gay
la fed e il canale tuo film quindi fai
quello che vuoi tu veux grazie era il
mio intento
devo ammetterlo tutto rosso il mio
sempai perché devo riconoscerlo perfetto
perfetto perfetto esattamente così se
noi mezzo agli altri non lo riconosce
così ma io ho la fortuna di poter fare
quello che voglio perché fortunatamente
ho tanti iscritti è brutto da dire vai
così quindi a me ne sbatte si tipo non
faccio 10.000 spettatori alive os in un
video faccio meno hughes perché ormai il
mio lavoro non è solo questo cioè io
lavoro anche fuori da youtube quindi
grazie a dio
posso fare quello che mi piace e vi
ringrazio per questo perché è proprio
grazie a voi se posso far permettermi di
farlo
perché sì ma gli unici a quello sono io
[Musica]
si
vediamo come cambiato sta faccenda qua
cosa ne pensi di debba fino ai pensi di
bagni go vice che tanta roba
glielo giocato per tanto tempo marco è
pazzo di quel gioco si va beh questa
intro solita non la puoi saltare ok
scusate non posso saltare la gente e si
nota spero se aiuterà in broken dai
giochi e se un uomo
dai ti prego salta la ve lo devo
tradurre e innamorata del suo senpai wow
come se non lo sapessimo cos'è quella
storia del luogo semplicemente uno su
instagram ha messo una foto di un nuovo
chiamato ward col record ed è quella
foto ha scritto battiamo il record del
mondo di mi piace che era apparteneva a
cahill non so mai come si pronuncia
jenner quali che non ho ancora capito
cosa faccia nella vita pro bono che
aveva fatto 18 milioni di like questo
record è stato battuto da sto uovo che è
un nuovo ne ha fatti 50 milioni tipo
altri giudicato i like di nell'altra dai
basta ti prego solvi fans come fare del
male si dai
madonna rega sì sì
there is nothing i voti per sempre
però io vorrei più ai dolci
mister e non c'è chi in famiglia notte
a si può scappare grazie come l'avete
detto qualcuno l'ha scritto premi e
febbre skippare non lo sapevo
f per scappare boc e tasto è non l'avevo
mai visto la scusatemi non sapevo si
potesse skip al meno male perché le cose
che sapevo ok niente abbiamo aspettato
un minuto e mezzo per niente diamo ok
non mi riconosco e dopo che non ci gioco
ciao francesco cosa dice nella intro che
ama il suo sempai punto posso andare a
scuola bene ma qualcuno qualcuno l'ha
mai finito sto gioco perché interessi
può finire
non so come però c'è si può
if the gamecrush zwei lodi inquisibili
visit di anders in punto com 16 clash
mick e non vi porta sfiga
per favore dovrebbe aver caricato
ok
meno male che va cacciato salve o mio
dio cosa è successo a gesù è forse
l'hanno aggiornato ragazzi
così è successo qua cos'è la band delle
forze che parlano posso fare gossip
chiaro yamada chi è chi lo conosce sorry
nevermind lo staccata dal gruppo
poverina poverina lo stacca dal gruppo
nolan aggiornato perché ci sono cose
perché quest'anno un innaffiatoio dietro
va beh siamo sicuri che l'hanno
aggiornato perché qua vedo cose molto
strane va bene e io dovrei fare la
stessa cosa ma non la faccio
dov'è il mio sempai ecco la coda davanti
si è lui
ok si tesoro va bene devo che guarda che
roba hanno aggiornato un sacco ogni
persona adesso è diversa prima cioè
proprio distinta che figo va beh cosa
bisogna fare andare in classe
fai a botte come faccio mica posso
picchia gen
selphy guai don knotts questo farmi dei
self i assetti mode o se io sto
camminando a caso che figo
io posso farmi se posso farmi servi con
stand by
questo è mai aspettato
che figata perché faccia fa vorrei la
faccia
cos'è e bellissima queste sempre ma
tanto io quando mando le foto non ho mai
capito a chi le sto mandando c'è
qualcuno che mi identifica la gente va
beh devo fare
vado in classe no ma che figo adesso
tutte le classi sono pieni anche quelle
18 che non sempre vuote cos'è consueta a
professori e portare le cose che figo se
qualcuno fa qualcosa posso riportarlo
che figo va bene andiamo in classe come
si fa
dov'è che come si faceva ad attivare il
il coso per terra che dice dove devo
andare
c'era un modo o c'era un modo però me lo
ricordo non sono pazzo cosa e non come
ho fatto come sito come amici oddio
eccola col articolati ho trovato procyon
tostapane in bocca ok perfetto con lati
con la ti vedo dove devo andare perfetto
no perché se non fai a botte con i bulli
vicino all'inceneritore puoi fare a
botte con i bulli va bene adesso vediamo
tutto vada in classe però è però queste
before class non devo aspettare come si
fa ad aspettare pastime facciamo l 87 50
dove la madonna che la cosa è successo
qua però gesù quanto la gara aspettare
il tempo
posso fare ok
biologia non ho mai capito qualche
server stavamo però comunque ora di
pranzo tutti che scappano che dei
compagni che ciò questo è veramente un
figo non so come ho fatto a non
innamorarmi di lui è roba non ci può
neanche parlare io ho accettato di fare
una cosa va non so cosa accettato il che
mi rende molto nervoso comunque ragazzi
c'è una roba molto più [ __ ] di prima che
adesso nonostante abbiano cambiato anche
un po le skin dei personaggi che lo
rende molto più figo adesso sembra che
la sua sia proprio più piena di gente o
è un mio mio modo di vedere la cosa
perché sembra proprio come lo sto
inventando ma sembra che ci sia più
gente capitolo che strano vabbè
fatemi andare a fatemi provare delle 99
allora fai vai a fare a botte con i tipi
di fuori va bene cosa vuole questo
questa mi segue quello che ti spacco le
corna madonna ragazzi libia
ve lo giuro vi ammazzo che si tengono
per mano che è successo e se più un
coltello 7 morte lo dico subito
questo è fatto male che è successo beh
la sua scuola è difficile difficile
questa scuola qua possono fare la chiave
del coni per fare in modo che nessuno mi
vedano posso darle una chiave dei
guardarvi devo rubarle la chiave zitta
porca vacca va fatto una ronda strana
l'ho presa le prese non glie lo prese a
cosa servono ste cose ma conservano stai
chiavi è come la fa più rubare ma glielo
preso no non è che un bug che le sono
rimaste lì in culo che peccato
vabbè dopo mi vide cosa servono le
chiavi non toccare le ragazze con le
divise bianche sono con i prof ma qua
tattoo sorella c'è mai spinto per un ora
ma io l'ammazzo altro che hanno toccato
il coltello ed eccolo visibilmente
armata come lo metto via come lo hanno
messo via come seguita raga non mi
ricordo i tasti come si equipaggia la
roba poi tra l'altro che questa c'è il
vice cos'è lo sguardo dagli under e vedo
le cose
vabbè vado a picchiare la gente vicina
all'inceneritore ragazzi per capire cosa
serve sta roba
ma ora che figo è cambiato tutto che
storia ragazzi mi ha detto di picchiarmi
devo devo picchiarvi però ti ho fatto un
complimento ad anche a volte finchè va
bene come faccio a me nave dove si
menano
posso semplicemente ammazzarli come che
si menano fink ha le chiavi lo prese un
bug che rimangono la va bene allora che
me ne faccio server aprile aprire le
chiavi in infermeria va bene non
marietto nei famiglia ma che mi serve la
marietto l'infermeria cosa me ne faccio
e vero ha mai forzato anche anche il
tipo si è alzato anche il tipo che era
morto si è alzato un tipico simbolo
mi dispiace mi scusi non volevo aprire
semplicemente mi serviva che figata raga
no vabbè ma è bellissimo
mi spiace mi spiace scusi sa bene che è
bellissimo
cavolo che lì non hanno finito di
giocare bellissimo bellissimo hanno
fatto gli aggiornamenti molto belli alla
prevista su due ti esce coltello e vero
hanno aggiunto un inventario come ho
fatto a fotografarmi la gamba cosa è
successo cosa è successo qua per ragazzi
bellissimo giuro
va bene allora due per primo il coltello
è nuova da mena i bulli melli meli meno
schiatta maledetto ad ammazzate oh boy
all
mannaia la morte ma muovi ti sei mai
andare a prender load 5
peccato non mi portano dalla consuelo
che dicono no mi dispiace non volevo ho
sbagliato io cerco di creda ti va bene
sei libera di andare non mi sarei
stupito di questo diverso di svolta
l'oggetto check point ma se i check
point che figata comunque è veramente
figo
ovviamente non puoi menarli tutti perché
sennò uno ti ferma francesco soprattutto
stesso giorno e allora segnato in un bel
giorno i ragazzi di campo grazie mille
non so non potevo menarli tutti però
fighissimo cioè è molto più fidanza cosa
che hanno aggiunto
devo far fuori una persona senza farmi
scoprire va bene
devo andare devo continuare a
disturbarli andando contro ok
proviamoci non so cosa succede però
proviamoci ma i bulli sono lì sempre
cioè che quando arrivi possono fanno
parte della scuola che è successo chi ha
mai sentito che questa roba
salve sto qua e una di quelle che spinge
ma perché per in divisa bianca mi
spingono sanno cosa ci hanno così divisa
bianca ma non lavora anche vista sta
roba
a queste sono le docce giusto guarda che
repulsione cia per il lo spogliatoio dei
maschi c'è proprio uno schifo va bene ma
in quello delle donne non ti spogliava
perché sono diventano un family friendly
però eh no non posso farlo mi spiace
nude schools in suite jimi un'iphone
scambiamoci ai ragazzi ragazzi
mi sa che mi metto come prima ascoli
uniforme ma quanti fai la doccia con
questa roba qua
eviterei di farla veramente divisa
bianca il consiglio studentesco e quindi
a sono tipo professor tipo professori
tipo madonna 4c giocata sto gioco regala
dei malati ok c'è niente vabbè e volevo
vedere semplicemente era giunto a no
questo l'avevo già visto questo era il
campo da qualcosa da volle a noi la
piscina wat molto figo va bene niente
favorevole volevo menare quei tizi che
vedere cosa succedeva però quindi fare i
farei venire i tipi e poi vediamo che
succede se sono ancora qua non ci sono
perché faceva una radio partita quando
vengo qua e diventa tutto oscuro che
succede devo andarci di continuo con tre
tizi ma sei sicura
mamma mia che palle aspetta un attimo
che arrivò ferme nardi devi andare devi
andarci contro più volte eccone uno ecco
l'altro tutti che si riuniscono al
cerchio satanico satanici doveva fermare
che succede qua eh ma non me le fa
menare a si è quindi che figo ajo
fregato il costo va dai ma dai che
figata di una catena quindi adesso poi
minare i bulli va bene ma qual è la
trama è lo sai tu no no figo figo
veramente figo non pensavo hanno fatto
molte cose e lo trovai ce l'avevano i
bulli ma date meno se non varrà secolo
non avesse visto avrei menato c'è
qualcuno che allora qualcuno per caso
guardato il mio sempai ma perché io vi
meno tutti questo è nazista anno
sembrava sentite devo devo andare a devo
trovare qualcuno che non è seguito da
nessuno in modo da farlo fuori senza
farmi vedere tipo questa
la madonna prendi prendi a posto qua non
c'è niente da vedere
non c'è niente da vedere qua ce l'avete
l'altro vi devo cambiare i vestiti
faccio schifo non c'è niente da vape mi
sa che lo trovano il corpo mi sa che lo
trovano le tracce sono un pelo evidenti
mi sa che si capisce dove l'ho
trascinato però ok non fa niente ragazzi
sto male secondo me equa finisce male io
ve lo dico da troppo la sua trascinando
tutta storta
lamela vorrei mettere qua dentro però va
beh
ok dovrei cambiarmi vestiti però questa
cosa non la posso far vedere volevi
vederla volevi volevi allora mi sono
visto denudando in questo lo descrivo mi
sto tentando complimenti continua si sta
lavando la zia ma perché la prima di san
ok ok ma che complimenti cioè la tipa ci
sta dentro ci sono i vestiti sporchi lo
rimetto non posso farvelo vedere ragazzi
venuti a volte ma non censurato sta roba
da giuro ho buttato i siti nella vasca
non ve la posso veramente far vedere per
questo motivo il non sto scherzando
ci sembra che vi sta tenendo in vita
prendendo in giro e però non sono serio
beghe anzi potrei mettermi in jimi
uniform ancora meglio dove don matteo
quando serve allora ve lo chiedo anch'io
guardali 9 stato io dovrei pulire mi
servirebbe tra l'altro l'arma la posso
prendere shinai si chiama troppo mettila
nel come faccio a metterla
nell'inventario non la metterei
diventare forse perché troppo grossa e
giampiero tu sei sempre giampiero né
sempre come sempre però sempre detto tra
l'altro
andiamo avanti ragazzi dovrei trovare da
qualche parte poi vedo bene tutte le
cose nuove che ci sono perché ci sono un
sacco di istanze nuove tipo questa cosa
sta roba qua per quanto è migliorato sto
gioco da 1 a 1 milione e bellissimo
guarda e vabbè comunque dovrei trovare
le cose per pulire per terra dove a
credo sia da qualche parte dicono i
bagni sono non erro
no no ho sperato però ciò spetta a tutti
ragazzi dove è cosa per pulire per
terminate una mano perché non è da juve
sia preso l'estintore lezioni iniziano
adesso beh figurati ci vado vestita così
dalla lezione come ci vado mi serve caso
per pulire per terra
devi buttare l'inceneritore l'arma i
vestiti sporchi o avere adesso li butto
un attimo che devo una cosa va primo
disco per terra tanto sono a lezione
però se non vado a elezioni non è un
alibi capito perché giudico doveri e
durante la lezione io posso fare lezione
qua no il trading intro lima da dovrei
trovare a e sul tetto c'è cosa ora
faccio così andiamo a lezione così sono
insospettabile perché se vado una
lezione non possono dire che però da
un'altra parte
perché giustamente mi dicono scusami
dov'eri quando c'è stato quell'omicidio
è no io la lezione ok quindi ho un alibi
e poi vado a pulire va bene però devo
fare veloce prima che arrivino i tizi ok
stato io mi sono seduto si sono alzati e
stata una pessima idea quella di andare
a lezione senza pulire prima perché
ignaro io pensavo che nessuno sarebbe
andata a controllare non era proprio
questo avrei dovuto prima in ceneri
il corpo è l'arma e poi fare quel però a
quanto pare ho sbagliato bene la polizia
ha trovato il corpo di sulu su cui
hamasaki
la polizia ha trovato lasci nike e una
arma sporca di sangue
ma come ha già trovate le impronte
digitali a iano io mi chiama jano è
stata arrestata e non vedrà e non avrà
mai sempre porca vacca porca va bene
allora adesso lo faccia non sapendo e
non lo sapevo re che non lo sapevo non
lo sapevo scusatemi la facciamo così
facciamo così li facciamo ma facciamolo
bene adesso facciamo così mi cambio mi
metto coi vestiti la palestra faccio
fuori qualcuno incenerisca milan mi
pulisco per terra mi ricambia vado a
lezione così non hanno o l'alibi ok
e o sbagliate non lo sapevo ragazzi non
lo sapevo le ragazze del consiglio ti
spruzzato in faccia in faccia se ti
vedono un'arma non lo sapevo va bene e
fa fuori il primo il bullo prima mi
cambio prima di cambio facciamo sta roba
perché sennò facciamo le cose a pezzi ok
sbarazza di dell'arma è ormai come ho
fatto a fare come faccio a farmi intanto
le foto e le gambe a perché il tempo che
tira fuori il coso ad ora attendiamo
ipes time invece l'hanno peggiorato
perché adesso e lacca prima non la gava
una volta non l'ha governata adesso lag
l'arma l'ha poi incenerire con il corpo
certo
ma vi siete addormentati
lo sta facendo lager dove sono i bulli
sono le otto sono i bulli le 8 so quanto
tempo per arrivare qua la pensa che ti
dico più al coltello
quanto tempo per i bulli sono questi si
sono qui ma quanto ci mettete valore di
aspettiamo dai non posso affrontarli
tipo prima tipo in mezzo al corridoio si
possono mamma mia che botte che sono un
piede di porco come i'm not in top four
two day perso con una ragazza zio
tanti auguri allora visibilmente armato
non fa non dà fastidio a nessuno se non
[Musica]
alle tipi del consiglio corretto ma se
questo lo facessi fuori qualche c'è già
l'inceneritore non ne faccio fuori due
boe veloce
aspetta aspetta tra calo tra veloce
veloce veloce veloce ti prego
velocissimo non c'è tempo
brutta lo buttano bravo bull veloce
perfetto attivate benissimo c'è l'europa
per terra e beppe signori non ci sono
tracce di sangue le anche questo non è
sporco di sangue perché non lo
stracciato buttiamo pur l'arma per
sicurezza open butta come si butta con
la butta non butta l'arma come faccio
come faccio a buttar l'arma ragazza
forse l'ho buttata nell'inceneritore 56
minuti o e la madonna propria facciamo
tempo a dare lezione signori vi
ringrazio per essere così socievoli
tutto questo è rimasto a questo perché
si è preso le botte si è seduto posso
parlarti un attimo complimenti ai 90
degli addetti un look lobuli dopo aver
nominato gli ho detto sta roba penso
proprio che tu sia carino dopo che lo
menato lo brucia lo procede o bruciato
tipo all arma e amate non c'è traccia di
niente e non lo non città e non posso
bruciarla e c'è il tipo dentro brucia
anche l'arma e non c'è sangue raga nota
chissene che sanno non c'è sangue ladra
elezione non è sporca l'arma posso dare
la colpa a qualcuno che manca o più e
non me lo fa fare
va bene ma lezione non so io ho fatto
fuori non c'è se non arma non è sporca
boh io andrei a lezione sul serio sono
arrivato un po in ritardo ma non fa
niente
vedi adesso non mi hanno arrestato tutto
in biologia
vabbè ci sono le impronte sull'arma
giusto giusto però non trovano il corpo
sono trovato il corpo non è che dicono
niente perché non magari il tipo è
sparito è andato che ne so e uscito le
terre è uscito residenti voi dove andare
a giocarlo è andata a casa quindi non
sanno che c'è un morto
quindi ci sono impronte ho capito però
non sanno che c'è un morto
giusto comunque sono passate un sacco di
ore direi che a posto non lo posso
neanche aprire l'inceneritore proprio
papà si spezzava accenni ma butta tour
al armi
quindi c'è chi o cosa dovrei fare dovrei
ammazzare tutti questo non fare il suo
gioco
no ho sbagliato a buttarlo vabbè vabbè
dai andiamo a casa mangiamo e andiamo a
casa
dovevo andare in domani ammazzo qualcuno
altro che ridere la gente gioco è
veramente rientrato più carino però è
sempre comunque come dovrebbero
migliorarlo un sacco di cosa devo fare
qua basta non mangio sempre biologici
sono fenomeni biologia mano mangio
possiamo andare a casa per cortesia
cleaning time
cosa vuol dire cleaning time per pulirmi
tempo di pulirsi cosa fanno queste ma
perché
succedono cose andiamo via via di qua
come si esce mai perfetto domani
ammazziamo qualcuno ragazzi sto gioco è
fantastico ve ne siano state neered
scure wait for sempre sicura facciamo
così cinque minuti di pausa e torno va
bene perché devo andare a bere e
pisciare 5 nuti hanein back lazio
my people
i'm back aveva fatto anche merenda
perché stavo scattando di fame a posto
siete si parte live terminale otto amici
questo è il primo era la prima parte
adesso devo far fuori
altra gente come ci siete timidi ad
eliminatelo ok
ripartiamo da posto
no molto molto bello gli under giuro
veramente molto molto molto molto molto
bello allora ripartiamo una donna quanti
commenti la che non risco a leggervi un
casino si parte dai
io ce l'ho più tardi stasera ce ne devo
andare a dormire quattro slick ma sulle
8 va bene tutto però mi ammazzo è che
inter ma come macro academy hight school
tatro cambiata ovviamente il colore di
facebook per l'hanno reso più l'hanno
reso meno facebook per non infrangere il
copyright per quanto facebook dove
sanyuan hold'em high schools a quella
trees are se qualcuno sa quanto sono
vecchi quegli alberi fighissimo
videogames ma c'è un gioco nel gioco
ma veramente come secondo cos'è sta roba
no penso per curiosità o gesù cristo
le immagini ha scalato mi lasciano
veramente perplesso sono morto non sono
capace
questi giochi di bravura capito ben
fatto da pasta va bene basta
sono contenta bene così per carità di
dio
andiamo avanti per favore bene vado
dormi sono le otto dormi l 8 si dorme
tra un ora vado a dormire a chi o ti
ammazziamo oggi lo dite voi
ditemelo voi ragazzi perché io vorrei
capire se si sono accorti che manca uno
studente come non se ne sono neanche
accorti invest
school concentrati non guardare le tipe
di fianco a del gioco è già ho perso
figurativo sta guardando proprio quelle
quella che devi live e vodka o acqua noi
interna di milano
vediamo solo pura pure vodka comunque
non era male quella dell'immagine di
prima del giochino gli hanno fatto
funerale a quello lì come potrebbe
essere scappato volo incenerito ma non è
vero che hanno fatto veramente vada in
palestra gli hanno fatto il funerale era
sempre quello se poi hai visto è proprio
un bravo ragazzo che pecca e non eri un
bravo ragazzo quindi no
ok che ti guardi che sostengo ne
compaiono come hanno fatto a capire che
la morte radio che ridere fa veramente
ridere comunque civico cona e la tua
ricchi eco con a chieco cona
scusatemi
chieco conan scusa e non so chi sia non
so chi sia stacco con datemi una mano
comunque bellissimo generale anzi va
anzi anzi
anzi spetta a proposito
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
ecco a posto ma salva reputazione più
uno c'è niente gli hanno fatto la tipa
quei capelli viola e la mia rivale
perché era una tipa coi capelli viola
con l'ala senso di più coi capelli viola
questa è capo di viola per la lunga
questa questa eco cona come ti chiami
gossip taro yamada non so non so non so
come si chiami chi è questa
assist a mente si sta mettendo il posto
sto male subire suzuki ok allora non eco
corna si è messa in posa perché l'ho
fatto aspetta facciamo così quasi 66 un
po [ __ ]
niente aspetta e mettiti in posa aspetta
draga egli è tanto il gioco dell'anno è
bellissimo è bellissimo o un pezzetto di
fallo li fa un'altra volta che te meno
immediate anche voi a me va bene non era
quella la mia rivale chiara mia rivale
fatemelo vedere ai codini sopra alle
pompe giganti
non so se la vedo la faccio fuori non la
vedo ok
cos'è l'angolo disagiati questo
ragazzi io non ci penso sia del c'è io
non ho parole per lo giuro bellissimo
la gente si mette in posa con i self il
fantastico ai capelli viola ho capito
quindi andiamo
di sopra devo trovare una quei capelli
viola non capiamo la prima lezione 67 48
bene la mia classe ok nella lezione
prima sonda solo facciamo lezione
geologia biologia sono bravo in biologia
allora ti pago i capelli viola vediamo
di morire quella cioè capelli viola
fermi tutti questa no questa pagan tutti
i capelli viola sto gioco come ha fatto
chi ha i capelli viola pdp così ai
tornati sulla testa
ok quindi il mio obiettivo e co co na
una che hai tornati sulla testa però non
la trovo alle pompe giganti va bene
troviamo la uno mi dice che sul tetto
all'altro amici che nel club di cucina
si sta roba ruote fa cos'è sta roba
questa faccenda gli androidi va bene che
[ __ ] la scuola in giappone ai boccoli ai
torna di questa è tornati e questa
cocona
aci como razza chi non è questa e di
fuori in giardino e nel club di cucina
questo suona la chitarra poi girando is
mettere la x non devi stare dentro le
sedie e suona suona pure non la trovo
sta qua ci mette uno guarda qui figo ma
hanno fatto un sacco di roba
vabbè non la trovo io sta tizia ma se
sicuri cocona la pop on a quella lì ma
non è che bella la scuola in giappone
alle codina forma di tornado appena la
trovo la faccio fuori però mi serve un
arma quindi ecco la non è questa ma
perché devo far fuori lei e lei la mia
rivale come fa a saperlo
eccola eccola e lei per forza più pop e
dico si fa con selphy cona
eccola qua allora ma mi sembrava
poverina perché solo perché ai propri
giganti che sta facendo quel che è una
persona normale tra di voi c'è the drama
club ma perché la voce da uomo e una
donna o no maschio
e jeffrey star vabbè mi siedo non posso
sedermi ti guardo così io vabbè basta mi
sono rotto mi sono unito al drama club
ma me ne voglia di andare coltello
quindi io devo aspettare che cocona se
ne vada e la faccio fuori va bene cona
per me pensavo si mette di spessore che
ad esse il vassoio niente aspettiamo che
esca aspettiamo che non ho capito bene
perché ma perché sempre innamorato di
questa strano proprio non ne capisco il
motivo se quella roba lì da ex al satana
a me non lo offre a dei scemo offre
anche a me ammazzo prima di lei è solo
perché c'è le poppe offre anche a me
offre anche a me
ovvia che a me caracas eccola il sori
aichen talk right now si sia quella con
le coppie le diamo le cose almeno è
perché mi faccio schifo
mamma mia mi ammazza tutti aspettiamo
aspettiamo un po quando si alza poi si
alzeranno spero ed io che ho capito
c'è stata a wright encomi devo aspettare
che vada in un punto dove non è visibile
così la faccio fuori però dovrei
cambiarmi prima perché se no vado a
lezione vestita da acqua gym quindi
vestiamoci prima dove sta andando
se poter poi fare quello che stai
facendo più veloce però che cade nel
latte alle ginocchia facetime standard
quanto tempo per uscire dal giardino
dove vai
poverina perché la devo far fuori che
figo ci sono ricco e le locandine dei
vari club
io sono nel drama club e per il quale
dramma dove dovevo essere solo nel drama
club è andata incassare andiamo in
classe anche noi poi scendo va bene
e dove che non andare pensionato
ecco con è innamorata del mio del mid di
sempre va bene
a posso tranquillizzare le persone ora
che sono un esperto di biologia wow non
sapevo chiede ancora di seguì la portata
del bagno ammazza la band icona colonna
era al piano di sotto non c'è più di
sotto di cona eccolo là mi seguì un
secondo per favore mi seguite mi seguì
un attimo task gossip us che favor
tasche by complimenti classic
beh facciamoci delle domande che la
prendo io
con l'uniforme dico cona è troppo
stretta trova un modo per trovargliene
uno è un po più larga prego non è
proprio quello che vorrei fare ma va
bene e non mi interessa e non come
faccio a farmi fare a farmi seguire come
faccio a farmi seguire da lei ti puoi
seguire gossip complimento o gli alberi
lobby che falsa va beh vorrei
il problema è che se la faccio fare in
qualsiasi punto è visibile ovunque
porca vacca che fa si doveva ma perchè
pulisce la scuola ma cosa gliene frega
vabbè non ho capito se clicchi punto
alla yandle e che lasciano le coppe
questo gioco si sta rivelando veramente
interessante però va bene è la tipa s'è
messa puliva la classe non so perché non
capisco ragazzi è veramente difficile
fare fuori una determinata persona ve lo
giuro
perché non si stacca mai sempre gente in
mezzo alle barre adatta è andata a casa
basta questa 6 nel club delle pulizie
si romperanno le balle ripulire a scuola
non so
riuscendo devo aspettare che faccia
qualcosa per farla fuori perché non
posso far africa perché c'è troppa gente
ma siete sicuri che lei il mio è il mio
ufficio nel mio obiettivo non sono
completamente sicuro è come fate a
sapere che lei che il mio metteva bene
devi parlare che un comune chiede lì o
top guarda adesso non mi parla manco
stazza qualcosa ti stai facendo così
importante non c'è la non c'è non c'è il
tasto seguì è sempre marcata da qualcuno
porca vacca sempre cooking club perché
poi anche se la mazza che non c'e
nessuno siamo troppo visibili capito
meno che nessuno mi vedrà passare in
corridoio adesso però proprio difficile
ve li c'e sempre qualcuno
porca vacca cioè club della cucina li
mortacci loro che fa ma poi andare a
qualche parte è difficilissimo fare
fuori una persona
andata si andò via dai dai dai dai
questi dolcetti vai via
porco schifo è proprio difficile far
fuori una persona no andata di nuovo al
club del dramma ti prego che è rottura
di tre quarti sto club
mamma mia oh c'è ma il pare che che
faccia queste cose quando c'è larga
devo completare la mia task per farmi
seguire da lei e come faccio come le
trovo un vestito più aperto come lo
trovo
se come se la faccio fare adesso nessuno
mi vede o si prova a farla fuori e non
farmi vedere da nessuno è difficilissimo
proviamoci laica misto cagato sotto tiro
la ok
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
preghiamo ragazzi
preghiamo che non esca nessuno è forte
se esce qualcuno dalla porta questo è un
problema aspetta fretta se qua chi se ne
frega delle chiazze stai qua lascia
lascia la io non ho fatto niente io
ragazzi sono veramente in ansia tira la
sto facendo lo slalom tra la gente
speriamo non si è fermata lì quella cosa
fai lì muoviti col demonio o chiese
mossa perfetto perfetto tira tira tira
tira però arrivare l'aiuto arrivare dal
gioco e l'albero li devo arrivare devo
arrivare laggiù stato questo è il
preside consuelo orme non lo so se il
presito cosa che si occupa dei delle
cose criminose di chi litiga ci aiutò
trascinando un colpo fuori dalla porta
spiega non ci senso nel corridoio dai ce
la faccia ce la faccio
le scale le scale ragazzi lo stesso
rumore no
balle puoi andare a farti cavoli tuoi
per favore chi sei
chi ti conosce amiche verso sporco di
sangue e dovevo farla fuori rega ma va
visto e lo sporco di sangue abbiamo
pensato 222 fate fuori due vai da anni
porta tutte e due nell'inceneritore
tutte e due via via via forza forza
quanto è difficile ma posso portarla in
braccio ragazzi ci penso
no non puoi prenderlo in braccio del
pozzo dragarlo avrai lag e
difficilissimo
c'è qualcuno in piscina tra l'altro non
è vero sto gruppo di pezzenti nora che
non ci credo
devo trovare un modo per evitarli questi
devo fare tutto un giro strano spremono
mi vedano faccio il giro largo magari
non mi vedono speriamo che un problema
se no che sì non stanno vedendo che sta
trascinare il corpo
vabbè
certo ammette devo aspettare che poi se
ne vadano questi che fasti di bulli o
poi c'è ancora un altro corpo liquido
rifare tutto questo proprio l'altro
corpo è ok sta qua detto posso bruciare
22 due corpi insieme si immagino e il
sangue lo devo pulire mi serve una
risposta veloce
ditemi se devo pulire il sangue perché
non lo so sta roba
poi sotterrata nel giardino davanti ai
bulli davvero brucia solo l'arma e la
divisa che non ti beccano perché non
hanno le prove va bene se mi beccano vi
ammazzo sì cosa si cosa che posso
seppellirla non c'è bisogno che la ince
nero ok va bene devo pulire devo qua o
che si devo pulire va bene grazie e
sheila
allora puri pulisco e un po di tutto sto
schifo qua
che schifo scusa ma mi devo devo pulire
o no perché se mi pulisco io e come
fanno a sapere che lo trascinata io
brucia solo l'arma e la divisa va bene
proviamoci
questo sporco di sangue ingiustamente
eliminarmi di pollicino devi per forza
bruciare i corpi va bene a quali stanno
a facebook i tuffi ecco che sto casino
puliamo sorridi pulisco pulisco non
posso pulirmi posso fare vedere psico
puoi scegliere anche i bulli e si può
facciamo fuori tutti adesso
paulina voci non posso farla vedere
strisciante devo pulire qualsiasi cosa
se non puliscono le robe mi beccano se
ne sicuri io ci provo a pulire tutto
però non ho capito e mi beccano no ci
sta mettendo un sacco pulirmi a
proposito se il premo punto chiama
mattia vabbè non posso farvi vedere che
sta per high school uniform cioè un po
strano andare in giro così secondo me
non è proprio il massimo però non devo
pulire tutto devo pulire o no non ti
beccano se non pulisci vabbè no no no no
no no dovevo della pulce l'arma l'arma
sto bruciando ho capito fammi andare
no mi beccano del suo show l'arma è la
polizia arriva a scuola elementare lo ha
bruciato l'arma
trovato i corpi dico con arouca e musume
rorschach è per forza porco demonio
morto cosa è successo stavo andando a
bruciare cosa stavo andando adesso a
bruciare cosa un attimo che è successo
perché così è successo regala no non ho
capito cosa è successo perché abbiamo
peccato che stava andando a beauvais
rifacciamo il pezzo della faccio fuori
strano
ero convinto perché è successo è finita
su è finita un attimo da butta cosa è
finita
niente arriva fuori cocona porco demonio
la pone vabbè che fastidio c'è messo
un'ora per far lavori poi il sangue pure
ecco non c'è un altro modo c'è un'altra
arma che non fa uscire il sangue prima
che la trova bernava e finita la
giornata ho capito sto andando a buttare
il coso un attimo un minuto perché
succede quando finisce la giornata che
ora alle cinque e mezza vabbè dai è
andata così ma che sfiga
definita la giornata va beh alle 18
finisce la giornata che non sa erano
sapevo di tema questo che capelli sa
cos'è cocona cocona non perdona peccato
perché ero arrivato fino a un certo
punto non puoi seguire mi è basta
che sfiga questa cosa che fa precisa
niente strozza di come come faccio
al club dell'occulto nuova vero rischio
al capo dell'occulto non capita aspetta
tutti stanno andando in classe adesso
cavolo ma vista la vedeva ammazzo tutti
attraverso il petto dell'altra vabbè
vabbè non avevo ancora visto sto finale
carino dai espulsa non lo è arrestata
espulsa york's 3 anche vabbè peccato e
niente va bene niente devo farla fuori
mentre non c'è solo è difficile chris
ciao chris sono già fatti sono christie
del [ __ ] ciao chris volevo chiederti
quando partiamo dal terremoto che si
portarlo è chris abbiamo giocato un
sacco mi sono divertito tanto mi
rispetti un sacco in the tra l'altro
però vanno man o da me l'hanno fatto
passare la voglia
peccato perché mi piaceva
dai facciamo la roba seria però che figo
lavata di grease
ragazzi e dove strozzarla colpire di
porco e vero però il piede di porco me
lo danno solo i bulli e non c'ho voglia
tanto mi stavo chiedendo in mezzo alla
porta e non c'ho voglia di rifarmi i
bulli che palle quindi niente a faccio
fuori pulisco vince nero e via
secondo me non cambia niente non è che b
ma cos'è che vinco il bin cosa la faccio
fuori quel succede
ecco kona kono
[Musica]
ma dov'è a mi sa che è andata in mezzo è
difficilissimo rega farla fuori
ecco poi prova e mezza la gente orribile
forse se le parlò mentre tutti gli altri
sono in classe perché mi gira
esattamente dove vai vai devine no il
club dell'occulto per cortesia c'è
capitolare il drama schifo club
che è rottura per questi vanno a scuola
prima cosa è successo
si sono ritrovati solisti ciao allora
facciamo così vediamo se riesco a
parlarle tanto tempo in modo da tener la
propria ferma che magari nessuno mi vede
cosa faccio fuori parlare di qualsiasi
cosa l'attivo complimenti grazie della
tengo ferma così la gente va via
questa sta facendo quello boh porca
vacca sarebbe finissimo farò fuori qua
esci grande a posto fa lei fa lei fa
tutto lei grande così mi piace anche
prima devi fare così
dove vai cioè che sta andando doveva è
pazza la porto nel spogliatoio così a
meno aspettare ma parlaci ok ti ha un
attimo forse ce la faccio e ragga forse
porco demonio arriva a quella in fondo
poi cosa uscite di lì andate andate a
fare in piscina datec esche che fate lì
in mezzo gossip
se io tengo qui in gossip e la tengo
ferma così nessuno guarda che esista
gente che sta gente qua
coco chanel info chan saurina romagna
dice troppa gente va in piscina non
riesca a fermarla adesso la faccia
quanta gente va in piscina
ok
via via via via chieti viene spento
nell'ospedale spiegato agli spogliatoi
esperto di spogliatoio
ok allora mi cambio mi lavo solita
storia che questa volta ci dovremmo
essere anzi forse stanca andare in
classe a fa lezione credo ok
allora l'unica roba che adesso
che schifo alla gente fa palestra
l'unica perché adesso c'è gente qua ci
sono stanno questi no andranno prima o
poi a lezione che guardi e ti guarda
speriamo che vada una lezione passatempo
non posso passare il tempo non si sa per
quale motivo rimaste sempre funzionato
posso provare a seppellirla solo che non
so come si seppellisce vediamo se riesco
a trovare l'accesso qua dentro non c'è
perché devo passare pensa di qua per
sempre la manica ci sono stile
efficienti indie che faccio dov'è che si
possa appellare scusate quanto è
un'impresa far fuori sta qua potete
andar via fastidio tradizione impronte
sangue che stanno dicendo cosa guardi
che c'è che c'è qui
cosa ti affligge nella vita spiega me
ce la fai portare la serie horror
residenti vocale dei demoni ti prego
farlo
vediamo adesso finisco sta roba vediamo
i bulli non valli in classe non gli
stanno la donna stando alla cia di cosa
ne pensi greta menchi è una ragazza
posso non posso passarci ovviamente
vicino come faccio elevarli questi c'è
prima ci ero riuscito perché era uno di
questi prima ancora che arrivassero
capito questi faranno qualcosa o stanno
qua tutto il giorno dovresti distruggere
il coltello va bene distruggiamo ancora
niente di stupro solo il coltello perché
la tipa non la posso di far fuori perché
ok il coltello andato
ciao la tipa non la possono seppellire e
non posso incenerire perché ci stanno
questi quindi va beh
[Musica]
e credo ci saranno in classe col costume
vabbè
ok va bene va bene ciao amici arance che
sono pure primo altro che alibi ma io
non ho niente non ho niente no no no no
coltelli non c'è nulla io sono in
costume a the police ha ormai volto law
kate anymore del web
[Musica]
cosa c'è adesso spiega che cosa
cos'è devi bruciare i vestiti pure la
mia unico i miei vestiti chio bruciare
il vestito il mio pulito allora devo
pulire adesso non pulisci non succede
niente non è vero da pulire ma anche un
consiglio decente mannaia roberts dovuta
la mia uniforme nell'inceneritore
ok è pulire vabbè cose adesso tutte cose
che prima non c'erano vabbè
prendo il coso pulisco che palle vabbè
dai tanto ormai so che giro fa avevamo
di fare cose giuste ti accoltello di chi
ascolta ce la faccio con te per il dio
20 lo via su togliti togliti chi ti
vuole dobbiamo le cose dove la spada la
roba per pulire adesso sto cercando la
scopa per pulire che non so esattamente
dove si sa però cerchiamo la
penso sia sopra nel tetto non sul tetto
giusto eccola qua a qualcun altro
coltello
così caso due coltelli
ok il detergente veramente che vivo
niente allora curry inizio già giorgia
lo riempio lo riempio perugia carrey che
arriva proprio ok in questo giallo porto
giù perché tanto già so che faccio
quindi lo porto giu
lo metto non lo metto dove per club
disagiati
ma ci sono i cosi come teoria c'è c'è un
chilometro per portarlo dove devo
portarlo vabbè bensì pulisco pure ma i
bulli devo picchiarli tutti e sei gli
picchio tutti c'è un problema allora qua
mettiamo questo ok intanto picchiamo
tutti i bulli se devo farli fuori
veramente a questi non sono i bulli
ok ci sto facendo tutto sto casino per
pulire
devo mettere pure il depura il detersivo
possiamo prendere tutti quanti ma chi se
ne frega del detersivo regata che palle
non mi va di fare tre volte il giro non
per buttarlo giù grande perfetto può
farlo prima
vabbè niente l'ho buttato giù perfetto
ho votato il detersivo dal balcone dal
detto quindi a posto ok
ok questa volta molto più easy anche se
non so dove sia la tipa vabbè cona
cocomaro na dove mettiamo questo coso
qua effetto non ho capito se mi devo
picchiare quei bulli manette necessario
lo faccio a scatola ma dove è cascato il
detersivo che non mi ricordo
non è cascato il detersivo ho perso il
detersivo cona dove l'ho persa era
andava andava di qua prima quindi
immagino sia andata in palestra
eccola cos'è teatro whatsapp cos'è sta
roba qua ma stai facendo
cosa state spiegami cos'è cos'è cos'è
che è alcolisti anonimi cos'è sta roba
qua a e teatro con li assistono e con i
recitano simpatico cosa fai sporcacciona
cosa fai
mamma mia scrive incastrare proprio tu
che mi servi populismo po con quel tipo
video ammazza tutti e due specie un po
di tempo
[Musica]
cioè è passato un ora di tempo quelli
che ancora stanno lì tutti se ne va
andranno in classe una certa no alle
otto e mezza mi pare quindi se non vanno
in classe e lido incastrati nella porta
tutti vani incassare sui tranne voi due
perché non riuscite il che mi rende
veramente felice iavazzo a tutti e due e
vince neri scorretto qui stanno correndo
perché vogliono andare in classe ma non
riescono perché io incastrati allora
state lì che vedo solo se ci sono ancora
i bulli sable lì ci sono ancora lì
picchio se no no demi si no posizione
sta mandando ragazzo ci sono banche i
bulli c'è questa un'occasione più unica
che rara guardala perfetto
raga perfetto da tu per tu perfetto
tutto perfetto tutto giusto
gli faccio fuori tutte e due che succede
al bagno nevaschi li faccio fuori tutti
e due
la borsa no eccoli incastrati nella pa
che trappola incredibile che ho creato è
che è professionista killer guarda un
coltello ciascuno tacco no
maresca come li fa colpi ma come si fa a
colpire a eva glielo diremo ciao ciao
marco
bene l'ho fatto e adesso inceneriscono
tutto super prima cocona che è un ora
che ha rotto lui una fa pure rima
perfetto ci mettono un po ad arrivare
fino al collo ma ci arrivo
ce l'ho fatta devo capire come buttare
cioè mi possibile rally tutti e due
mi rispondete se post incenerirli
entrambi domanda mi serve una risposta
abbastanza rapida perché sono in cene
disco solo cona
posso farli tutti e due
sì sì sì sì sì sì sì no sì o no non
posso metterli tutti
sì ma uno alla volta una volta ea non va
bene tutti e due
uno alla volta ok allora niente
[Musica]
sì ma non devi attivarlo vediamo dunque
non c'è modo di prenderla in braccio
dopo trascinar mela che rottura
speriamo che non e seconda a crescono
dalla classe all'una ma è altra domanda
ma io devo per forza andarci in classe
perché se non ci vado
poi sono sospettato che uno è andata a
scuola è un killer però sun si sa mai se
sicuri
dai c su è uno l'abbiamo portata ma
anche l'altro no no che attivate anche
l'altro manca tutto ma il coltello
bufalo non era quello giusto mi sa di no
che attiva i top che activate to sorella
activate manca tutto manca manca la devo
pulirmi tutto devo fan forum cattività
devo mettere i vestiti i vestiti pieni
di sangue come faccio
è uno strazio questa cosa è quando
youtube non era se ne fregava la sega
nessuno potevamo fare ste cose
adesso neanche più ok a carrie lei li
butto proprio ciò che succede
ce l'ho fatta in teoria brucia questi e
io farei anche una pulitina davanti
all'inceneritore che fa un po schifo
picchia la scopa molto bene ma veramente
devo mettere chi se ne frega delle
impronte
chissenefrega incenerisce vai bene ma da
lezione in swim suite
ho bruciato l'uniforme ho bruciato
l'uniforme e il corpo manca l'altro
morto che sta la è però i non mi ricordo
quale coltello li ho fatti fuori va beh
manca l'altro corpo chissenefrega tanto
ho bruciato l'arma ho bruciato i vestiti
non hanno niente che riconduca meno
liberi ragazzo non lo posso bruciare c'è
già attivato l'unica allora facciamo
così siamo sicuri vogliamo essere sicuri
ma me ne vado a prendere il detersivo
pulisco brucio pure il corpo del ragazzo
però ci metto di più vera per evitare di
farlo detersivo non è detto che è
successo quello mi sa che in ritardo a
lezione ciò questo dubbio devi pulire
per forza sono atp al dna va bene trova
il detersivo e poi bullismo no no non so
dove è caduto detersivo devo farmi tutto
il giro quanto tempo va in teoria dovrei
farcela anche quelle e ritardo per la
lezione qualcosa mi dice il tipo non me
lo sono dimenticato non può entrare
l'inceneritore perché ci sono già gli
altri
eccolo fatto detto zio l'ha votato qua
so non l'ho buttato facevo prima
va bene devo a pulire
ok non i colloqui detersivo ok lì a
pulire tipi di beckett write
puliamo very good
adesso devo ripulirlo di nuovo non curry
puliamo le altre tracce premiata per
ridere importante
non sto ridendo
faccio degli scatti strani con la faccia
però non si può ridere perché si ride
premi z non sia agli under e si calma
non è vero non c'è modo di vivere
ho premuto z però non va pulisco mamma
mia quanto schifo no
che schifo quanto casinò era che qua c'è
una chiazza bella gigante come faccio
mamma mia che strisciata rega è infatti
dopo un po non devo in versarlo trame
che deve ridere non posso prendevo pre
valori perdutamente
vi si è ridotta icona al gioco sta
premendo ripetutamente giusto lascio la
scopa facendo non va
avete detto cagate come sempre devo
pulire ed aprire d'arco demonio sto
[ __ ] cose inutile spogliatoio degli
uomini inutili
allora
ok effetto
ma devo tenere premuto va bene
quanto
va bene così
va bene così ho fatto io tanto prevenuto
giusto
va bene così giusto z prodotto cioè so
cosa serva no
sto pulendo dito un casino perfetta un
casino dio mio
pulisci la sima senti poi smetterla di
sanguinare per favore per cortesia te lo
chiedo per cortesia smettila
smettila basta ok schifo
ecco a boss drag la scopa devo buttare
si immagina
adesso devo premere più volte control
cosa state dicendo
io per fare il tempo che ha fatto tutto
sto casino ha fatto in tempo a
incenerirsi quella roba là
favi contro il pizzetto maraga non
funziona guarda oro premolo tengo
premuto non si non puoi ridere in questo
gioco che stai a di
io non ho mai visto che si può ridere
anche fosse non l'ho fatto
quindi non lungo seconda volta sta cosa
non si può più fare ho premuto tutti i
tasti che avete detto
è il lavoro del killer
grazie grazie marco
ma perché i figli ancora le lasciato me
lo chiedo anch'io figurati c per fare
tutto sarà vano impiega sei ore che
arrivò in classe che sono ritardo di due
ore a devono bruciare anche la scopa
ecco quello non lo so se devo brucia la
scopa non l'ho capita ci siamo
amen
guarda quanto ci ha messo in tutto sto
casino io devo bruciata la scopa
no non devo bruciarlo se la brucia e
meglio vabbè consigli sempre over the
top e la l'acqua ecco nola è più che
altro l'acqua dove la butto dove cavolo
health ih oh pulito talmente bene che
non mi ricordavo dove la una roba
perfetto ok abbiamo quasi tutto io
l'abruzzo è
secondo me non si può bruciare la scopo
anche se non è però va beh qui io
figurati se una volta non passò davanti
al suo spogliatoio del demonio ridire
serve a calmare il battito se no ti
scoprono è ma non ride
ci ho provato come avete di [ __ ] contro
z contro z e ha premuto schiaccia tutto
fatto beni che posso bruciata scopa sta
che sta ancora fini di incendi va bene
prossimo ormai è un è un hobby perfetto
lo scopo adesso lo pulita in realtà poi
adesso anche non bruciarla più basta che
però l'acqua la debuttare capito che
l'acqua è sporca si vede curry l'acqua
la bruttura dell'inceneritore con la
valuta l'acqua della bhutto dove la
butto l'acqua ragazzo serio una party
scalzi queste 6 questa sera all aria
l'aria l'acqua dove la butto l'acqua
l'acqua l'acqua da buttare acqua da una
brutta una cosa una buttana butta la
butto l'acqua l'acqua l'acqua l'acqua
l'acqua nel bagno incenerisce anche
l'acqua ci ho provato non si può l'acqua
a chi se ne frega
lo butta volevo buttare patate che non
si rovescia neanche l'acqua nel
lavandino vediamo no non puoi farlo set
bug sta dicendo a una cimice impostato
nel bagno
non devo buttare non la devo buttare
l'acqua
posso anche non buttarla va beh io la
vedo se riesco per curiosità se no per
ridere dei premi con devi premere contro
ripetutamente sono funzionate mi hanno
premuto va bene adesso provo attivato
l'inceneritore che non mi ricordo più
intanto poggio questa vedo se riesco a
buttarla dove l'ho trovata se sì bene
sennò amen e poi provo a calmarmi se
riesco che se no così abbiamo finito in
teoria lo attivato l'inceneritore non mi
ricordo più
vediamo se non ha facoltà re o
incredibile sono riuscito a fare una
roba gehrig allora tracce finite
coltello c'era ancora in mano altro
coltello ma in realtà non ci ho fatto
niente col secondo coltello ma
produciamo pure questo che chi se ne
frega corpo vestiti in cioppi niente
sono solo arrivate in ritardo a lezione
no non l'ho attivato che adesso vado
attivare spero che non faccia niente se
sono arrivata tardi a lezione
ho fatto tutto raga ho fatto un casino è
la scopre pulita possa anch'esso alla
laboriosità puliti chissenefrega
[Musica]
il coltello buttalo noi lo puoi buttare
vuol dire che non è non è chi se ne
frega soprattutto l'immondizia top
coltello non lo posso buttare ma tanto
questo qua non è quello che ho usato
allora contro il tieni premuto con per
ridere di tenere lev control
ripetutamente se non funziona tenendo
premuto ok bene andiamo fino a ciao ho
attivato l'inceneritore non una volta
che pirla ok non è sporco i vestiti e o
bruciati o bruciato le alre ma ho
bruciato i corpi o pulito per terra ho
buttato l'acqua se mi beccano io me ne
vado
sono le undici chiama lezione in costume
va beh signori o 11 precise ai am sorry
iwas david e febbre c'è anche l'altra
azione
chissenefrega tutto in biologia vai vai
jolo nama casa che quella che non ti
conviene
ragazzi io sono esperto era contro
comunque era con tutti a scrivere brevi
z break e uno scrivano a cag ata in chat
tutti dati lo copiano non era z era
contro la ragione
chi è marco marco grazie marco che mi ha
salvato grazie grazie mille grazie mario
10 caffè tutti verne grazie mille let's
go
dopo adesso me la godo
al drama club del drama club si è
sciolto perché non ci sono più membri
va bene a dormire
mercoledì no tutti stavano a dire che
era z no contro letto io sta tranquillo
got to school va bene
raga ho pulito tutto siamo il funeral
eno
[Musica]
express varibile un euro e mezzo perché
sono rimasti incastrati nella porta c'è
vabbè
[Musica]
signori auguro buona cena a tutti
vi ringrazio per aver seguito online vi
mando un bacino di alzi mille cose video
è piaciuto lasciato un bel commento
non mi piace anche l'isola cioè chi come
noi vi trovate nella descrizione se non
si discute vi è come sempre ci vediamo
al solito è la prossima
ciao ragazzi